du portefeuille au sac à main ici chaque
pièce est unique
des créations que les visiteurs ont pu
découvrir à la cour des métiers d'art de
versailles une première pour marie
dominique hamonou je présente de la
petite maroquinerie essentiellement à
destination des hommes parce que j'aime
bien de travailler des collections un
peu coloré je trouve que ça change de ce
qu'on trouve ce qu'on peut trouver
actuellement dans le commerce qui est
toujours un peu noir marron etc
j'ai commencé à beaucoup travailler en
ligne mais là ce que j'aimerais c'est
c'est pas me faire connaître sur
versailles déjà puisque j'habite à
versailles et puis sur les yvelines en
général un échange avec le public pour
transmettre et partager son savoir faire
ce fait des démonstrations couture au
point de selliers donc avec une pince à
coudre et c'est une culture qui se
réalise à la main avec un fils et deux
aiguilles c'est une couture qui est qui
est garanti quasiment à vie très solide
et qui rend à qui fait un point
magnifique qu'on ne peut réaliser qu'à
la main une méthode acquise auprès d'un
artisan maroquinier d'hermès et avec un
ca péages sur sa fille c'est chez elle
que la jeune femme met en pratique ses
compétences depuis deux ans découpage
collage
elle réalise environ une quinzaine de
pièces par semaine entièrement à la main
aujourd'hui porte cartes en cuir
bicolore une première couche de teinture
donc là c'est pour finir la tranche en
fait jusque là on voit on voit bien
qu'il ya les deux les deux cuir collé et
donc la tranche elle va finir une
teinture qui qui recouvre les deux est
toujours un peu travailler avec mes
mains c'est à dire que mon père était
très bricoleur il était mécanicien donc
en fait on a toujours un petit peu
bricolé dans la famille donc j'ai
toujours un peu travailler avec mes
mains et quand il ya trois ans je me
suis posé la question d'une reconversion
professionnelle c'est vrai que je me
suis dirigé
danse et voilà quoi un travail qui
s'inscrit également dans une démarche
écologique
la créatrice récupère ses cuirs en
ressourcerie c'est du réemploi
donc c'est lé cuir qui proviennent de
chutes et de fins de séries de grandes
maisons donc c'est quand même des cures
de qualité mais qui sont réemployés qui
ne finissent pas à la benne parce que
c'est leur destination au final donc ça
me permets moi de travailler des cuirs
de qualité et de proposer effectivement
des produits qui sont abordables pour
tout le monde
30 euros pour les plus petites pièces
les sacs peuvent aller jusqu'à 189 euros
à l'avenir marie-dominique soit encore
plus développé le sur mesure un terrain
de jeu et de création infinie